I wanted to bring on my boy Jason Locker
fora he was the Redskins beat writer
there no7 my last time there now he's
the big CBS national guy doing all kinds
of stuff you can check him out on
Twitter he is the CBS NFL insider at
Jason Lakhan fora on Twitter Jay always
appreciate the time man how are you
I'm good I left part of my soul and
heart in that little media room chasing
you guys around that parking lot there
at Ashburn so you know there's still a
piece of me out there Rock well you were
very very good at it and because of you
a lot of people call me the rooster
because you wrote about that day my
nickname because somebody when I was
with the Redskins the first time told
you that my grandpa came to training
camp and call me rooster yes everybody
seemed to love that my buddies call me
rooster that's a whole other story but
alright so I want to start with the
Antonio Brown stuff Jason so I guess my
first question is what happened because
I went to bed at 10:00 I woke up at 4:00
and it felt like Antonio Brown got or
did not get traded twice during those
six hours hours you were asleep actually
in terms of like football stuff nothing
happened honestly I mean I guess word of
a dead trade got out and sort of was
presented as real time when in fact by
the point it got out it was there was no
trade to be had because the player
wasn't going to go to Buffalo and you
know it was no point continuing the
dialogue and and both teams had you know
had gone their separate ways so he
didn't miss anything any idea what was
right yeah well any idea Jay what the
what the trade compensation would have
been I've seen a couple people or rumors
that maybe they were gonna swap
first-round picks and then some I'm not
sure I don't I don't know I mean I
you know I'd heard they were pretty far
down the road and that you know this
dealers were comfortable with what they
thought they might be able to get but it
was you know more hypothetical than
anything else because the player by that
point had made it clear he wasn't going
to report and the bills didn't want the
aggravation and you know wasn't even
like a contractual thing I mean they had
never reached a point where the agent
was was negotiating anything with the
bills because there's nothing to
negotiate because he doesn't play there
he telling me he won't play there so you
know the team has moved on so okay so
we're talking with Jason Lakhan fora CBS
Sports NFL insider so Jason two weeks
ago Kevin Kolbert said that a Antonio
Brown would not have any say and where
he gets traded I mean it sounds like he
does well I mean the one thing he could
always do is take his ball and go home
right and and say I refuse to report and
you know come after me find me whatever
so you know I guess the one card you can
always play is you know I'm retiring I'm
not showing you know have fun without me
card which you're right it does it
doesn't affect the negotiations but it
will scuttle it will scuttle them real
quick if the team you know just loses
interest and says I don't want to play
that game with you either and and yes
that's what happened here I think what
Kevin was alluding to was the fact that
this players you know signed a record
contract at the time not that long ago
and that's three years remaining and you
know we're not going to give him
permission to seek a trade we're not
going to run this through the agent and
let him bring a deal back to us we're
gonna do what we have to do for our
football team and then we're going to
trade him and if he wants to get you
know more money somewhere else that's
between him and that other team and
obviously in this case had never even
got to that stage because apparently
Buffalo's not on not on his list I mean
if you're the Steelers right now you've
got to be having flashbacks to last fall
to trade deadline right when they're
trying to trade Le'Veon Bell who says I
don't ever want to play for you but then
as his agents calling team saying don't
trade form because we're not going to
report so it's like it's there it's
there a part of both of their
subconscious that really is
still wants to be in touch beragon at
this point people in that building are
wondering well a they've got nothing
really cooking with any other teams
right now there's there's nothing you
know they've they've had they've had
conversations here and there but there's
nothing ongoing and then B they're
wondering like is this just some kind of
weird subterfuge to eventually try to
get more money out of us to stay here
because you know where does he want to
go you know like it's it's pretty
bizarre well and I think that's a good
point because it's like okay well the
other teams that were rumored to be
interested like the Raiders and Redskins
is he is he you know doing cartwheels to
go to those places and he has complained
and said he wanted to be out of there so
they they came up with a trade to get
him out of there and then he said he
wouldn't report so I mean the steelers
could say hey well you got to stay with
us now you can't complain you said you
wanted out we got you out but you didn't
want to go so that'll be very
interesting to see how that ends up
unfolding I wanted to get to some other
stuff with you as well I think I saw a
video where I believe you said I don't
want to put words in your mouth but that
Kyler Murray going to number one to the
Arizona Cardinals is the worst kept
secret right now is that correct
thoroughly convinced that that is going
to happen yes okay so then that
obviously means Josh Rosen will be going
somewhere else I think you referenced
perhaps even like the Redskins
so so here's our San Jason a guy was the
10th pick or whatever in the draft last
year 11th whatever so if you are the
Miami Dolphins Washington Redskins I
would even say teams with older
quarterbacks like the New Orleans Saints
New England Patriots LA Chargers New
York Giants why wouldn't almost all of
those teams be willing to trade a
second-round pick for him well I mean we
can take him team by team Miami I mean
other than Adam GaSe nobody that
organization was convinced that that
Tannehill was the you know was the guy a
year ago
they could have drafted him you know to
me they could have made moves to get him
last year they didn't I don't think
there aren't any hurry to get a
quarterback right now and that's also a
team that's probably looking at next
year's draft knowing they're more than a
year away saying to Herbert okay but we
like that and they're controllable for
five years and they're cheap too and
we're not inheriting somebody else's
problem
they took him a 10th overall you're
right and moved up to do it but there
didn't seem to be much conviction behind
it particularly if they do what
everybody in the league thinks they're
gonna do and take another kid in the top
ten
a year later doing well if I'm doing one
jacobi percent contracts up in January
right I Got News for you if Tom Brady
gets hurt this year they ain't going on
the Superbowl with Josh Rosen and they
know Jacoby reset they're comfortable
with Jacoby percent I heard that they
weren't big old Rosen last year in real
time they like Lamar Jackson more than
Rosen I don't know that they felt he was
a culture fit or of those five
quarterbacks he's the one I heard the
least about them connected to so I don't
know that they necessarily like them I
mean New Orleans they got Teddy
Bridgewater right there and right now I
don't see a seat at the table for a
starting quarterback Teddy Bridgewater
is 26 years old if he doesn't go to
Miami I don't know where he's going
assuming Falls goes to Jacksonville so I
think they'd be just fine with that I
mean and dude they just they just gave
up a lot to get Davenport a year ago
like a - and and and draft the kid had a
buffalo day - and develop him I mean the
Chargers Matt maybe maybe they've done a
lot of work on quarterbacks - the last
few years but if I'm the Chargers why am
I the team to give them a - like Who am
I really competing with maybe Washington
I don't know you know I mean yeah I did
see a 180 like that very often right
I mean you just don't and and and this
kid had no chance to succeed and they
devalued their own asset to a point
where now they're going to be selling
incredibly cheap on them and that
problem is five quarterbacks in the
first round last year at least three are
going this year we've seen an
unprecedented quarterback movement the
last two years supply doesn't meet
demand as Nick Foles
well but what's interesting to me about
that and we're talking with Jason Lakhan
fora the CBS Sports NFL insider you can
check him out on
at Jason Locke and flora is you know
I've seen a lot of the different people
Daniel Jeremiah other you know draft
experts that will tell you that they had
Rosen with a higher grade than drew
Locke they had Rosen with a higher grade
than even a guy like Dwayne Haskins for
some of them so in my mind even like the
Giants right I mean you give up a second
round pick for Rosen and you could use
that number six overall pick on a pass
rusher or a D lineman that they so
desperately need right I mean I I I'm
surprised I would think that there'd be
multiple teams that would be willing to
give up a second-round pick I'd be
shocked and you're the insider you know
more than me but I'd be shocked if they
didn't get a second round pick for him
maybe they do maybe it works out that
way that just talking to people around
the league who don't have skin in the
game saying you know I mean if you were
this team what would you offer if you
were that what would you offer what do
you think's fair I mean I think the
problem what Rosen too is people we can
look at draft grades but we're talking
human beings and he wasn't and and I
thought a lot of this was BS but it was
reality
he wasn't everybody's cup of tea and the
at the profile the personality profile
test and all that stuff they make you
take the way he scored out in that
freaks some people out and then he went
to a place that literally quit on him
like in less than a year like so where
is he psychologically you know what I
mean where he was sacked fifty-two times
like I'll go back to our redskins days
what did Steve Spurrier do to Patrick
Ramsey you know what I mean and Joe
Gibbs couldn't fix it like I just think
there's that element to it as well I'd
rather have a blank slate with a kid who
I bring in and indoctrinate everything
rather than you know what I mean I'm
gonna go get this guy I own it and I'm
wasn't sure how much I loved them in the
draft and you know what I mean now I got
to try to rebuild him like it's one
thing if it's show McVeigh gets the job
and the job is go fix Jared golf and he
spends an entire offseason rebuilding a
mind body and soul holistically
confidence you know what I mean ego all
the way up if that's what this kid needs
unless you you know I mean less you
think he's your absolute answer I don't
know that you're doing that and I don't
know that you're able to do that on the
why if your New Orleans or the Chargers
and you're trying to win a Super Bowl
the Giants one is interesting I'm not
sure that his personality fits what they
their model of a quarterback interesting
Jason always appreciate the time always
good to talk with you as soon as I saw
that that video on your on your Twitter
I wanted to make sure to chat with you
about it thanks so much as always my
pleasure thank you buddy all right there
he is Jason Lakhan Fora from CBS Sports
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]